I simply ask Republicans in the Senate
to give him a fair hearing and then an
up-or-down vote if you don't then it
will not only be an abdication of the
Senate's constitutional duty it will
indicate a process for nominating and
confirming judges that is beyond repair
it will mean everything is subject to
the most partisan of politics everything
it will provoke an endless cycle of more
tit for tat and make it increasingly
possible for any president democrat or
republican to carry out their
constitutional function the reputation
of the Supreme Court will inevitably
suffer faith in our justice system will
inevitably suffer our democracy will
ultimately suffer as well
I have fulfilled my constitutional duty
now it's time for the Senate to do
theirs presidents do not stop working in
the final year of their term neither
should a senator I know that tomorrow
the Senate will take a break and leave
town on recess for two weeks my earnest
hope is that senators take that time to
reflect on the importance of this
process to our democracy not what's
expedient not what's happening at the
moment what does this mean for our
institutions for our common life the
stakes the consequences the seriousness
of the job we all swore an oath to do
and when they return I hope that they'll
act in a bipartisan fashion I hope
they're fair that's all I hope they are
fair as they did when they confirm
Merrick garland to the DC Circuit I
asked that they confirm Merrick garland
now to the Supreme Court so that he can
take his seat in time to fully
participate and its work for the
American people this fall he is the
right man for the job he deserves to be
confirmed
I could not be prouder of the work that
he has already done on behalf of the
American people he deserves our thanks
and he deserves a fair hearing